four score and seven years ago our
fathers brought forth to this continent
a new nation ladies and gentlemen
Abraham Lincoln let's give him a big
round of like wow mr. president you
don't know [ __ ] I know you look
ridiculous how about why flowers
balloons Larry David what could be
better
can I give you a little tip if you're
gonna confront somebody and it's better
than do it with pants on it's hard to
take a person seriously wearing shorts
everybody's a big Johnson community
knows can't wear underwear there's a big
Johnson community I'd like to see if I
can join how are you getting in the big
Johnson community without a big Johnson
begin hey yeah I need you to do me a
favor I can't do it no no you got to do
it early get my sweats on what is it a
mutable law of physics once you're twice
you can't get out Newton's law of sweats
I think you could introduce me as a
Renaissance man Oh a guy who speaks six
languages you want to impress people
with lines how else to impress them I'm
gonna [ __ ] you get the hell out here
with pleasure
okay
get the [ __ ] out I want you out to check
them out and you can go to do you meal
yes Johnny I'm
[Music]
you